let's talk fast about the scale of this
problem
rape cases are at record highs over 60
000 cases reported to the police in the
year to september 2021 convictions at
record lows an estimated 1.6 million
women the victims of domestic abuse 680
000
women victims of sexual assault 110
women killed in the uk by men in 2020
can you in good faith tell women
watching
this interview watching us talk that if
they suffer violence or abuse and go to
the police that they'll get justice in
this country
good evening and thank you for inviting
me along this evening yes in answer to
your question i do think that women
should and must
feel confident in reporting offences
relating to sexual assault domestic
abuse to the police because we are
absolutely determined to address what
you've just described as an epidemic and
we know that and we want to prioritize
changing how we work within policing and
how we address
the challenges that we know we've got
ahead um and maggie um
i guess part of the argument has been
that the police could be part of of the
problem not the solution and there's a
number of reasons i say that but one
reason is when i uh interviewed the
prime minister about this back in
october at conservative party conference
i asked him about the appalling
statistics around rape prosecutions and
he said to me people don't have enough
confidence in the criminal justice
system and they don't have a feeling
that the police are handling these
issues fast enough which has led to this
feeling of fury and frustration so he
kind of put it back on the criminal
justice
system but also on the police how do you
feel about that when you hear him say
that do you share some of the blame or
do you think he's shifting the blame
i'm listening to what women and girls
say to me every day at the moment and i
think that trust and confidence issue is
absolutely right
and policing knows that
we've lost the trust and confidence of
many communities particularly women and
girls
across across our country and that's
something that really concerns us um and
we we know uh particularly in the last
few months and some of the events some
of the tragic deaths of of women last
year have really really changed um how
some communities particularly women and
girls feel about policing so yes we hear
that trust and confidence
and maggie i mean
one of the good news is is that you've
been appointed the lead in the police to
actually tackle this across police
forces so uh priti patel the home
secretary said to me that she wanted to
make it a national priority and she's
put you in place which means it has
become a national priority which is a
positive thing but i guess the thing is
is that
what follows through from that and one
of the questions i had for you
is that
does your appointment does the fact the
government's making this a national
priority mean that in practice the
government now might hit these rate
review targets that they set
and that was to get to nearly five over
five thousand prosecutions and nearly
three thousand convictions by 2024
that's going back to 2016. you'll know
all of this uh levels last year
prosecutions were 1500 just to put it in
some context can you give the commitment
today now that you think with you at the
lead and this prioritization that the
government can hit those targets and
women can have confidence by 2024 the
government will hit those targets what i
can talk about is i'm absolutely
committed to
ensuring that the things that need to
change do change within policing but we
also know
that we have to work with other sectors
with a range of other different
organizations including
the cps if we're really going to make a
difference for the criminal justice
system as a whole so i'm ambitious for
change and i know that we have a plan
and will make some uh significant
changes over the next year two years
moving forward but we we're talking
long-term
in terms of really changing realistic
are they those
in terms of really changing the
attitudes of men and boys towards women
and girls is going to take time that
isn't going to just happen overnight
that we're going to see and i
increasingly
i do want to come to that but they're
not realistic targets are they i mean
let's be straight i think we have to
have targets for improving both charges
and prosecutions around rape and serious
sexual offences and domestic abuse we
have to have those targets and the cps
and the police are working together
around them but we also have to be
realistic
that the criminal justice system alone
and particularly on the back of a
pandemic where we know we've got the
backlogs in the courts we have is it's
going to take time to bring those
changes and until we address the trust
and confidence which you you you
introduced at the beginning i think
we've got some difficulties ahead
just to be clear then
the targets are important but the time
frame might not be hit is that fair i
think the time frame it's going to take
years to really change our criminals
okay so not not being realistic not yeah
not hit by 2024 which i think is a
fair and straight answer
um
let's talk about the police and your
role
the evil case devastated women's
confidence in the police and and that
was compounded by the policing of the
vigil at clapham common there were the
whatsapp messages about rape and
violence violence and domestic violence
from the charing cross police station
and then this week there was the strip
searching of a young black girl child q
at her own school which has has really
upset with upset people
it's a problem isn't it
the incidents and the cases and the
particular matter around child q are
really disturbing and are shocking shock
me and shock the people that i work with
and i think even more reason why we need
to have a plan and a priority around
tackling violence against women and
girls it's on the level of of an
epidemic in terms of the information and
the data that we have
you outlined at the beginning we know
what the problem is so we we know that
it's it's an issue for society and
therefore what we see in society we will
also see in policing but we also know
that this is something that we have to
keep shining the light on and the more
that we do i think the more cases we're
going to see coming to light around our
own workforce around police officers and
staff
behaving in a way that falls below the
standard that we would expect within
policing and we will root that out and
already are on the way to do that
through the plans that we have because
mag actually you now you bring it up i
mean dozens of male police officers are
continuing to exploit their position and
take sexual advantage of women 66
officers and members of the police
you'll know this face disciplinary
proceedings for alleged abuse of
position for sexual
purpose have you witnessed any of these
attitudes among your colleagues
personally first of all just to go back
there there is an absolute plan to root
out any any behavior or conduct that
falls below what we would expect in
policing and the many officers and staff
that i work with and i have led over the
last few years want that we don't want
people in policing that uh bring down
the reputation of policing
and don't fit with the ethics and values
we hold
are so important so really important to
know that there's that plan in terms of
what what um i see i i yes i i
experience and see what women tell me um
they've faced within policing and and in
other professions working alongside
policing um and it's really important
that we have a culture where those
things are talked about amongst our
teams and our supervisors and women
concerns you've been a senior police
officer you you've
personally experienced sexism and i have
been really supported in my career
through policing i wouldn't be here i
wouldn't be doing the job i'm doing if i
didn't feel that policing is a fantastic
career and something to enjoy and be
part of that's really important i think
to get across i want women to come and
join policing i'm really pleased we've
got about 42 percent in our latest round
coming to join policing but yes i i've
seen sexism and i know that misogyny
exists in in police forces
and police the police service as a whole
and and really important that we tackle
that it exists because it exists in
society but i think there also is
perhaps something about being attracted
to power being attracted to
um
a culture that some
largely men may find find attractive and
want to come into um and uh because of
the co the ability to coerce and abuse
more people that are more vulnerable so
i think there's always that possibility
which we see in other professions as
well
and our vetting and and our culture has
to be one where
in teams people can have those
conversations and call out and feel that
they will be listened to if they feel so
you feel the more women in the police
force the more that dilutes that culture
that male culture i think it does it
absolutely dilutes it but also diversity
and and having men as we do have who
want to be
very strong allies for calling out
inappropriate culture and being part of
that change
just one quick question on
the most prominent police woman in the
country cressida dick um did you think
she was treated unfairly or was it
understandable she had to go how did you
feel about that as a fellow senior
policewoman the met commissioner is a
fantastic role model for for women in
policing um
her resignation really is a matter for
um the mayor of london and the home
secretary so i wouldn't comment but a
great role model for women in policing
so you found her inspiring absolutely
absolutely um
let's just tackle another problem i'm
actually running out i've got so many
questions um you talked about male
culture in the police but is the real
problem against with violence against
women and girls male culture in our
society has it got worse or are we
getting more vocal about not putting up
with it i i think very much the latter
i've in a working career of over 30
years and i've seen changes in in that
working career around our society but
there are attitudes we know still
prevail and i think a tipping point
which i have referred to others have
referred to as a watershed moment of
last year coming out of the pandemic the
spotlight that's been shown on what
happens behind closed doors and
sometimes in in public places to women
and girls and the everyone's invited
website that's set up by by girls and
young women um accounting for the things
that have happened to them i think women
and girls are saying enough we we don't
want to be treated like this we don't
have to have and put up with that type
of behavior and that is a moment in time
for me and my career for for me um as as
a woman in society and i think we need
to grab that moment
and to use what we know with that
information you started out with this
morning the epidemic in front of us we
need to be able to address it but
policing has to do that by working with
other
agencies with education with the rest of
the criminal justice system with with
health because ultimately this is i
think a public health issue around uh
violence and maggie obviously focus of
forces help
people speaking about it
helps but in practical terms what would
help you in terms of policing would it
help for example if misogyny became a
hate crime would it help if public
sexual harassment became a specific
offence i want to keep the spotlight on
violence against women and girls
i want there to be lasting change for
how women and girls feel safe in our
society i want women and girls to trust
policing and the plan we have i think
we'll get will go a long way to that but
i think it's a complex one misogyny is a
hate crime the government has accepted
the law commission advice that um it
won't be um included as a hate crime and
policing
enforces the laws we don't make it um i
think it's perhaps a very symbolic
gesture to have have done to make
misogyny hate crime but perhaps doesn't
really get to the root of the problem
that if we sexual harassment
well well i think the root of the
problem is behavior and attitudes of
boys and men we've got lots of offences
already
and we know that consistently we don't
use them as well as we should across our
43 police forces we don't use some of
the protective orders that we've got to
keep women and girls safe well enough so
let's get working on that and let's get
looking at the education and the
changing attitudes of boys and men
before we think we need more laws
because i think prevention and education
and tackling attitudes isn't necessarily
about creating new legislation
so i'm not entirely convinced but we
will work with government as they look
into
whether new laws are needed around
street-based harassment
and we will we will want to recognize
that there are additional pressures in
the 21st century online that might mean
new legislation well we are going to get
the online harms bill so well look
maggie i would like to carry on but i've
got to wrap that but thank you for
coming on and i hope you'll come back
again in a few months time and we could
look at some of the stats and see if
we're going the right way or the wrong
way thank you thank you so much